astronauts have to deal with a lot of
dangers in space deadly debris harmful
cosmic rays and sometimes a corned beef
sandwich
in the 1960s at the height of the space
race space food was either compressed
into utilitarian packages or pureed into
a tube
nasa did this in part to reduce the
dangers free-floating crumbs could pose
like wreaking havoc on the space
capsule's instruments
during the gemini 3 mission astronaut
john young
didn't quite get the memo when he snuck
a contraband corned beef sandwich into
space
sure the sandwich could have caused a
life-threatening accident
but hey wouldn't you want to know how a
sandwich tasted in space
here's how the event played out between
young and his co-pilot gus grissom
elapsed
roll time five five
what is it corn beef sandwich
where did it come from i brought it with
me let's see how it tastes
smells doesn't it
yep it's breaking up is it
i'm gonna stick it in my pocket
it was a thought anyway
yep
not a very good one
and nasa in congress didn't think so
either young was reprimanded for his
actions but luckily for him the incident
didn't derail his career he later was
part of the apollo 16 mission and walked
on the moon
but that time he made sure to leave his
packed lunch at home
you